all right welcome back bros to darks
[ __ ]
to blood-borne yes so last episode we
finally finally we beat two bosses the
last one took forever and I am not very
happy about it but it was my most erotic
experience of my life it was pretty hot
there's a guy here I've been in a
[ __ ] machine guy an [ __ ] I
discovered we need to go here that's all
I know
don't shoot me and Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Araneta don't shoot me
you shot me [ __ ] crazy grandpa this
is me when I when I retire just put a
[ __ ] machine gun to my wheelchair bap
bap bap to the top spinning around in
ma'am oh god it's not a grandpa no
grandpa no what'd I tell you about using
the machine gun grandpa come on come on
please fall down please fall down come
on
Wow [ __ ]
taste my ass oh ah no no my ass only did
two damage damn it I thought it was
better than that are you [ __ ] kidding
me
what this [ __ ]
nope a Chan I can't deal with this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you grandpa
hahahaha yes I was worth it okay here we
go finally we can enter [ __ ] everything
let's try this big guys devil oh it
works Jesus please don't be a boss fight
I'm not ready please don't be a box fine
it's definitely a boss in here I swear
to God
there has to be a boss in here yep I was
right
oh my god what do we got it's a blanket
I'm so scared
what is it what's a blanket gonna do oh
god no no no oh hi hey hey you look
great today
alright let's see what you got ow half
my health no big dick out there second
half third half of us sorry I walked
into you changing your makeup and I'm
dead
slap that Bodi girl slap that booty slap
that Bodi oh god what is happening I
have no idea what is going on I'm just
keep tapping attack and see what happens
oh god I got hit you promised you
wouldn't hurt me baby slap that ass with
some dais in the ass I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna kill her
that was the easiest boss of my life I'm
so good at this game
prey slaughtered how that was indeed a
Sluttery do little dams Megillah lev why
did we kill her exactly we're so mean we
just go everywhere and just [ __ ]
everyone up take this
you guys are just gonna keep shooting
aren't you oh they forgot about me where
that's just deer big knee VPP Fifi
birther burger
oh my god that was so [ __ ] close you
were close oh god these are so [ __ ]
scary I don't want to kill you you you
want to kill me though oh they're really
[ __ ] strong yep
stop attacking Jesus Christ Jesus look
at this
get rid has to be an enemy here I don't
trust this is that a light let there be
light
oh I walked into something I shouldn't
have walked into it's a dance party I
love dance parties yes just kidding why
was I not invited how dare you dance
without me Oh God aren't you dance party
now hub why aren't you dancing oh god
not these again
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
chill chill out chill out chill out
chill out chill out chill out said gel
there we go see they're not that bad
look you [ __ ]
no what's happen that [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes my soul's my blood souls
they're back to Daddy okay this [ __ ] is
not gonna push me down ain't no [ __ ] is
gonna put me down
but uh but you know you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god I would have
[ __ ] kill myself
oh ha ha ha ha ha ha I smell a boss
battle it's near boss battle incoming
yep there you are
now what the [ __ ] are you
are you a boss you can't be a boss
where's the witch where's the witch
where's that [ __ ] um excuse me
oh there's something oh my god you [ __ ]
she took half my health you are one ugly
ass [ __ ] aren't you you will pay
for being this ugly Jesus Christ where's
the witch hey we cheer Ichi that ah I
see you your [ __ ] no yes
you ugly ass ho Wow hey who's the
mushroom now huh
no oh God it doesn't matter how many
ugly [ __ ] you are I'm gonna [ __ ] you
all I have low standards don't worry
about it you are uglier than your sister
girl what the [ __ ] was that
what did she do ah she's eating me don't
eat me don't like this not a fan of this
not a fan of this don't do that two
dates stop dude stop doing that told you
to stop doing that there to that she
resurrected our [ __ ] don't you dare die
don't you dare die
oh I am based now
you will pay for being this ugly oh you
missed to you Haven here oh you missed
twice [ __ ] oh my god I don't have to I
don't have time I don't have time I
don't have time oh god I'm so dead
I'm so dead don't touch me again I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go um that is so
unfair if I die there don't hit me with
the balls she hit me with the balls what
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] this is this is it this is
this this is my moment
where's your balls where's your balls
where's your balls [ __ ] with some bowls
where's your balls wait yo boss wait yo
boss [ __ ] wait your balls
there's my balls no don't call me [ __ ]
you don't you dare touch her yeah so
something the Bears misled mmm that's
good
oh all right we're gonna end up so
they're good episode I liked it we like
to continue this series bros I really
appreciate your support
it's really awesome game i really love
annette rose stay awesome
did I just